[Music]
rude doctor news
submitted by Jessica from Georgia loves
Geo
oh hi Jesse I love you
she likes the Georgia Peach and ER
doctor was suspended after video shows
her berating and accusing a patient oh
yeah what sex on the premises I don't
know where we have a shortage of medical
professionals and doctors so we need as
much support that way we shouldn't be
firing doctors oh it was just a spended
only for malpractice can I watched his
video by day oh so here we go this is
the video well first of all this is a
victim slash patient his name is Samuel
20 years old he collapsed at basketball
practice and he has a history of anxiety
attacks so he collapsed from anxiety
damn dude anxiety and being a sports
players kind of like oh my god the 3.0
and he [ __ ] collapse because like you
know that's a really win that five four
three two and then they [ __ ] shoot it
and everyone watches the ball and you
hope that it makes it is that the same
anxiety is like stress anxiety though
yeah I think anytime stress they should
pull him off the court when there's like
10 minutes left
oh I see plenty of time to process the
whole thing yeah it usually does take
medication for anxiety but he has been
so busy with work and school he just had
it he didn't have time to go pick up his
prescription so he ran out of his
medication so he wasn't taking it during
that time and so he went into the ER
with his dad and so his dad started
filming this interaction that he had
with the doc is here in college or high
school college okay sweetie
yeah when he 20 healthy and he's
throwing up and he's going in and out of
consciousness I literally saw him go get
him out of consciousness he's
yeah this hospital
you know this hospital he's going to
have another anxiety attack just like
that one because he's in the same shape
that he was and he doesn't have clocked
him because he doesn't know you know he
doesn't know I'm sorry sure you were the
least sick of all the people who are
here who are dying there so you picked
your head up now don't try to tell me
you can't move oh yes Thank You Margot
you're literally helping you up you're
helping your ideas Oh
so this bad boy you want real you to
your house in the gurney yes you can you
can do it now I just tried to inhale and
I even thought sir I cannot Wow I'm
telling you Oh she'd be seen as druggie
she looks like Peter Griffin you have
changed your story every oh yeah that's
how pissed off you've gotten me okay
those guys are being extremely patient
cuz if as soon as the doctor started
talking [ __ ] I would have requested a
different doctor that's true that's
really she she's definitely gonna lose
her license where's that at this is in
Los Gatos Clara County is it California
California that's crazy oh very
what was her problem like was she
thinking that did she think he was he
was faking it
because that's no way to treat a patient
even if they are faking it that's
supposed to you're supposed to believe
what they're saying and the one point
one valid point that she did have is
maybe he did have the least fatal
illness or whatever but even then you
can't talk to people like that that's
just yeah that's [ __ ] off he was
probably working along [ __ ] she's
probably just stressed out is offended
from the hospital so she's no longer at
taking care of patients at bat Hospital
and that they just apologize to her like
she's banished she's a [ __ ] yeah
isn't there like a Socratic oath that
she has to live by
I don't think Socrates would act that
way and on top of that she's probably
angry because she looks like [ __ ]
Peter Griffin no that's true she looks
exactly like Peter Griffin yes sir her
name is dr. Beth Kings strap or dr.
Peter Griffin I know that physicians
have an issue or Hospital have an issue
with patients lying about that's why she
was asking about the narcotics thing a
lot of people want to have like they
like morphine me like all the other [ __ ]
they want to get like pain medication
all the time which is a issue that they
deal with every day like in the ER yeah
they're trying to milk the system
because people get hooked on opioids and
all these things and then when they get
off their prescription or whatever
they're hooked and they're like holy
[ __ ] what am I gonna do I didn't get my
[ __ ] so then they go to the ER fake some
[ __ ] so they could get you know their
pills I do not like the way morphine
makes you feel it is terrible
you literally feel you feel immobile you
know I mean I guess that's what people
like though because like it when I had
the morphine drip like it
it made my chest feel warm for a second
and then you just get all loopy and I
guess that's what people like I never
did morphine for me it was like I felt
it go through my IV and then I felt it
climb up and I was really cold and I
went up to my back and then like tensed
up my back like crazy no like ah that
sounds amazing but it was the tingle
went over my chest and then into my face
and then I was like I really selling me
on this
[Laughter]
blast look all right take my money few
things that I haven't done is morphine
now you've got me curious I wanna break
a [ __ ] arm or something
I felt so tense in my muscles were like
sore as [ __ ] after a wore off it should
be a relaxing how come you got morphine
oh I had just kind of my appendix taken
out oh yeah but morphine is wild you see
how can I you don't feel no pain just
curious like when people what do you
need to do to get morphine I don't think
I've ever had morphine I yeah it doesn't
make sense how my muscles should have
been should be the other way around I
don't know good that should maybe it
felt so good or just actually was not
great I didn't like it either yeah but
people people like they're addicted to
that opioid feeling when it makes you
just loopy and that's what people enjoy
but that's not what I hate I hate that
feeling I don't like not being in
control so it's very irritating for me I
like being a little bit out of control
but I don't do drugs anymore what about
when you all did not do out for your
eyeballs huh yeah the fall theme was
knocked out oh no I was just I was just
an awake enough so I could keep my eyes
open
I was completely conscious they only uh
and it's that Detective Tammet eyes my
eyes oh no I had my head I had an
anesthesiologist with me so like babe
they gave me just enough where I could
stay awake so they kind of like I get
scared of that [ __ ] don't put me I can
barely feel anything at all and so when
they were doing it and I came out and
the operation was done apparently I was
in that recliner for about two hours
trying to recuperate and for me I was
like I looked I went out to my brother I
was like dude fastest five minutes of
your life here that you were in there
for three hours so bad because like the
anesthesia took a long time to ico and
they said yeah how long was my procedure
15 minutes yep that's pretty fascinating
I don't want to go under I just I rather
just yeah you do it's fine really
yeah cuz then it's like you're nervous
because it's like a surgery or whatever
is about to go down and then you count
three two
you're out and then you wake up and it
feels like five minute no I'm afraid to
never wake up that's the problem
oh my gut needs fixing and then I go to
sleep sorry we [ __ ] [ __ ] up and then
I die I want to be awake for that [ __ ] I
would be like alright I'm done
alright I know I'm done alright okay
[ __ ] it they [ __ ] up I'm gone I've not
been knocked out three times and every
time I was like [ __ ] yeah this is dope
dude I ain't waking up cuz I'm like what
happened to my Friday I don't even want
to wait I don't want to [ __ ] wake up
not like when I got my appendix taken
out I woke up and they put the [ __ ]
the what is it called like for your
catheter yeah that one the catheter and
then so like my pee hole was hurting and
then my stomach oh why you got Jim
appendix pink taken out oh because there
had burst it er it was about inflamed
yeah it was after I was born so I had
just had a c-section Oh nine months
later I got my appendix taken out you
probably shouting the appendix was in
there that's the part that everyone says
you don't probably don't need right you
know what I need it only horses have a
big ass one they found out that it was
useful for someone yeah recently they
found out some [ __ ] maybe could eat raw
grass or some [ __ ]
is that anesthesia as well because
alright when I hurt my back in that car
accident I had to get like a localized
pain shot and so they had to put you on
report and I was like mad coffee cuz
like I just wanted to know so she told
me that when I got the anesthesia she
was like well you can knock you you will
knock out or you won't right but it's
not so it's very innovative what they do
so it's not a it's not a big issue so I
was like all right cool
I must stay awake so as she's like
counting she was I'm gonna count I'll
let five ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one five ten counting
whatever right and I was counting right
and I was like damn like the human mind
is really powerful this you could stay
awake through anything problem was as I
said that I woke up and I was out for
like three hours again but in in that
like weird like unconscious state I was
complimenting myself I would like dude
David you can when you put your mind to
something you could do anything
oh oh sir you were out for the longest
time no idea yeah I was out for ever but
that's when I realize like it's
literally
that but I counted and I thought I was
awake through the whole thing and I
wasn't
have you ever pretended to be
unconscious absolutely that when my mom
would be like it's time for school
I was in a really bad car accident
and when they brought me to the hospital
you know how they don't know if you're
paralyzed or not
so they just cut right through your
clothes we just strip you down like that
and they put the gown on you and then
they can't supported me and then they
put me on the stretcher and it's all I
can hell of pain and that's all just
laying there and under like sir we're
gonna have to do a cat scan or whatever
he is they're like are you awake and I
was like and so the nurse told other
nurse oh he's still unconscious he
hasn't woken up yet so we got to be
really careful on my man these guys are
actually really nice
and they just carried me and they put me
in the Bing and they slit me they did
the whole like but what was the purpose
well I don't get the purpose wanted to
see what what happened nothing what
would you do these are [ __ ] playing
with your dick
oh yeah pretend to be longer I wouldn't
have minded oh my god if I saw that even
that's cool trying to help but he was
pretending to be asleep I was like I
would just go literally oh really
you are the forehead no you're [ __ ]
around is like you ask the wait the
[ __ ] but they couldn't they couldn't
tell that I was attending which are you
doing this they don't know I'm sleeping
yeah is he still unconscious I know you
he's not away when a kid pretends to be
asleep there is no right now dude Oh
what are you show that she was me when I
was about to get beat I'll be like
trying to [ __ ] I'm so sleep right now
[ __ ] your eyes are fluttering at the kid
because you don't know you can control
through the [ __ ] door open I'm like
holy [ __ ]
[Music]